ah
[Música]
claro que sí la influencia canadiense
hace parte del proceso desde el proceso
de escritura del proceso de la
elaboración de la canción
de estar viviendo aquí en este país de
estar compartiendo con la gente de aquí
de estar escuchando la música canadiense
y muchos aspectos de la música folk la
música
pop y rock kiss y mezclarlos con con
nuestras tradiciones y nuestra música
tradicional colombiana entonces la idea
es de mezclar de tener este par de d
tener este esta mezcla de las dos
culturas y poder expresarlas disponerlas
de esta forma
yo creo que los canadienses son muy
abiertos a explorar otras culturas
y notablemente con la música que hacemos
a los que les encanta bailar entonces en
cada uno de los shows que hacemos el
contacto y él
la expresión más rápida que tenemos de
los canadienses es que se ponen a bailar
y cuando las cadencias bailan pues es
una fiesta y entonces es lo que nos
anima
yo creo que desde siempre y siempre
a medida que vas caminando en tus sueños
quedas haciendo cositas pequeñas y vas
avanzando en el sueño
convierte en todos
en este momento por ejemplo la música lo
es todo para mí es mi forma de expresar
una forma de respirar de comer de vivir
exacto yo creo que
es todo un proceso un proceso en el que
uno se encuentra uno mismo en el que uno
se define a sí mismo